coup de tonnerre dans l'émission pour
203 contre 256 l'Assemblée nationale n'a
pas adoptée le gouvernement constate que
sur l'une de ces mesures phares dont il
nous a rebattu les oreilles pendant des
heures et des heures et bien il n'a pas
de majorité pour le faire sur un article
ils ont une cinquantaine d'absents bon
nous on est mobilisé donc ça aussi ça
veut dire qu'il y a une il y a chez eux
des signes de faiblesse quoi
se lèvent cette vidéo tournée par l'un
d'entre eux
que cela soit interdit les micro
finissent par être coupés quand certains
députés de gauche commencent à entonner
on est là je n'ai pas pris ou pas au
vote nous avions décidé nous avions
décidé dans le groupe le matin de voter
contre cet article est un article alibi
qui est en gros ne sert à rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cet article rejeté prévoyez la mise en
place d'un index senior pour les
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés les
organisations syndicales nous avaient
dit depuis maintenant quelques jours il
faudrait passer de 300 à 50 salariés ce
que nous avons fait il faudrait durcir
les sanctions ce que nous avons essayé
de faire mais la gauche notamment a voté
contre la maman de Sylvain Maillard et à
la fin l'index est supprimé la première
fois qu'on a réussi à mettre un coup
d'arrêt dans le dans l'avancée du
Gouvernement sur ce texte il les
échouent sur cet article 2 c'était
vraiment une très bonne nouvelle et le
moment où en fait ce que dit
rassemblement national se confirme c'est
à dire qu'on peut avoir une majorité de
rejet sur ce texte on l'a vu ce soir
très largement c'est la preuve que si
les oppositions s'opposent le texte peut
être rejeté donc c'est une première
victoire on espère qu'il y en aura
d'autres derrière ce vote n'est pas
compréhensible il est davantage
politique et il démontre que l'objectif
des oppositions nups et RN n'est pas de
faire battre le chômage et les
injustices mais de faire battre le
gouvernement le gouvernement dédramatisé
annonce qu'il soit réintégrer l'index
senior dans contexte qui sera soumis et
débattu au Sénat à partir du 2 mars au
rythme de 12 amendements par heure il
reste 13800 amendements et au rythme
actuel il nous faudrait donc 150 heures
même si nous allions deux fois plus vite
il resterait 500 heures de débat or il
nous reste 28 heures et 30 minutes
l'enquête démarre dans une petite ville
près de Tel-Aviv en Israël à la
recherche d'une société qui n'a ni non
ni siège social et pourtant elle est
bien réelle à leur tête d'anciens
généraux de l'armée des services secrets
israéliens leur métier l'influence
encore une enseigne de mode française
qui ferme ses portes le chasseur San
Marina va tirer le rideau samedi et eux
ils vous disent ça coûte 50000 euros
pour faire une écoute téléphonique si
vous voulez faire reporter un scrutin
saboter un scrutin dans un pays
d'Afrique ces 6 millions 6 millions
d'euros
Silvio Berlusconi définitivement
acquitté à l'instant dans un vaste
procès pour corruption au terme d'une
quête il y a pas de témoignage il y a
pas de plainte il y a pas de main
courante il y a pas de signalement il y
a pas de fait répréhensible reprochés
les fêtes bunga bunga le réseau nommé
aimé propose des dizaines de milliers de
faux profils qui vont inonder les
réseaux sociaux de fake news ou
d'informations orientée au profit de
leurs clients qu'est-ce qui fait peur où
sont les menaces est-ce que c'est
rappeler le cadre de la loi fait peur
j'ai envie de poser la question à ceux
qui se sentent menacés qu'est-ce qui
vous fait peur le présentateur de BFM
c'est Rachid Mbarki voici le genre
d'information qu'il diffuse dans son
journal de la nuit un forum économique
accueille des investisseurs espagnols au
sud du Maroc forum rendu possible par la
reconnaissance par l'Espagne du Sahara
marocain quand vous dites que l'arcom
pourrait retirer si cela continue
l'agrément aux chaînes en question vous
interférer
avec les décisions de l'arcom le
journaliste mis en cause s'arrangeait
pour demander ces images en dernière
minute une fois que le rédacteur en chef
est pris sur une autre tranche et après
qu'il est validé l'ensemble de son
journal il y a pas d'autres que BFM est
victime dans l'histoire